I am Kalon okishima I'm a sculptor and a
landscape architect there's three parts
to it my design philosophy and how I
approach sculpture as well first is
creating places of contemplation and
that is creating these places of calm
I've been practicing meditation and I
was looking at the parallels between my
practice in meditation and how that
relates to my practice as an artist so
in this particular project five stones
it's not meant to just be an object but
also meant for people to sit within the
work itself because I'm trying to create
a very meditative contemplative
reflective environment the second part
is the research we want to try to
understand obviously the culture the
history the environment even the social
aspects Guangzhou was unique in the
sense that we did our research and we
looked at a number of different aspects
as we do for every location the first
thing we normally do is look at maps
when we looked and researched Guangzhou
there was so many knobs but rather than
at just being a two-dimensional form
like you would see on a map was that
maybe it'd be interesting to actually
walk into a map third part obviously is
how you can amalgamate sculpture and the
environment as one both are influenced
by the practice of meditation as a form
of researching the site and that's the
way in which we can make each project
not only meaningful but also have it be
memorable the Victoria Park project it's
a series of stone blocks that have been
sawed cut if you look at that work it is
an abstracted topography and river skate
of water and stone and it basically
addresses all of these functional
aspects for Singapore it's quite an
honor to get an award from the president
there's a certain credibility and gives
you a better platform for you to get
your message across to people my advice
to emerging artists would be to find a
way to incorporate
in your day to day life to have moments
of reflection meditation and
contemplation and give you the clarity
you need by minimizing your distractions